All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite. You scared me. So sorry, it's true. You're so excited. I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in. Yes.
And you know it's been well reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons. So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. Look at us, we're all getting together, jumping on here, and it's our first time seeing each other after our spring break week. Yeah. Yeah.
How's everyone feeling? Does everyone feel like real relaxed? Yeah, I've definitely slept for a week. Did everybody take a break? Yeah. You did? I watched all of the pit. I watched all of White Lotus, all of Righteous Gemstones. I have two episodes left of the pit, so don't say a word.
OK, I won't. I won't. All right. I have two episodes left of White Lotus, so also please zip it. You're in for a treat. Won't say anything. OK.
Yeah, I finished it last night. I just read that it doesn't have the same theme music, the whatever that music is. Each season is different. Yeah. Why? I read, because they had a falling out, the composer. Oh, really? What? Yes. Are you guys spreading the dish? You guys all went on like, like this real like, I'm gonna step away from like social media and I was like, give it to me, I'm home, give me the guss. You're just scrolling through all the stuff. Also you went to a very fancy party, Ange.
Oh. Okay, you guys, I need my- You can tell it's gonna be good if she's downplaying it right from the start. Well, here it is. First of all, I think my license for small talk should be revoked. Why?
I don't think I should have small talk. I don't know this story. No, you guys, I'm just, I think I'm out of practice. What did you refer to as being in a candy jar? Oh, Sam. Sam, I as being in a candy jar? Yeah. Oh, Sam. Sam, I wish it was a candy jar. Okay, okay. Well, I didn't go anywhere for spring break.
I just stayed home and I took just kids to doctor's appointments. Everyone got their teeth cleaned and you know, Isabel and Jack had their wisdom teeth consultations. I did like eight doctor's appointments, I think. I went and got my yearly women's exam. Good, good. Yay, I did it eight doctor's appointments, I think. I went and got my yearly woman's exam. Good, good. Yay, I did it.
Okay, so I did all of that kind of like, you know, tending to my garden, if you will. Sorry, that sounded wrong. See, again, take my small talk license, take it away. So I've known Glenn Powell for a long time. Jenna and I met him together years ago at like an award show party. He was so nice.
He's the handsome actor from twisters. Okay. Okay. Correct. And he's also from Texas and we sort of did that like, oh, you're from Texas, I'm from Texas. And we exchanged information and like every once in a while over the years, we'll just check in with
each other like, Hey, how's it going? Or congrats on this or he'll invite me to something or I'll invite him to something. And he's just such a great guy. So I see online because you know, I'm home scrolling that he has a new line of condiments like condiments made with organic ingredients and it's called Smash Kitchen. Okay. Barbecue sauce, spicy mayo, yes. A whole line of them.
And I just DM'd him like, hey, this is fantastic, congratulations. And he's like, thanks so much. He's like, are you in town this week? I'm gonna have a little thing to celebrate it. Are you around? And I said, I am. And I'm thinking to myself, oh my gosh,
we didn't really do much over spring break. This is going to make Isabelle's day because she is such a big fan. So I text him and I say, I can come. Can I bring my daughter? And he's like, absolutely. That would be amazing because like, you know, his parents are going. This is like, like a family affair. There's going to be wonderful barbecue and lots of good dipping sauces. Anyway, I
tell Isabelle and she loses her mind. And can I tell you guys what I wore? Yes, of course you can say what you wore. Thank you, Sam. I wore a sweater I got at the mall ages ago. Like at a little, you know the little pop-up kiosk in the middle of the mall? Yeah, I couldn't even tell you, like, it was just one of those randos I bought. And then I wore my tennis shorts. Love it. You guys, I wore tennis shorts!
That's on brand for you, it's great. I know, but I was like, well, I don't know. You looked adorable, by the way. Thank you. I did my own hair and makeup, and Isabel and I go, she's so tickled. We go really early. We're like the first people there, you guys. It started at seven. We arrived at 708. This is so us now.
I know. And I said, Isabel, we're just going to stay two hours because we wanted to get back home and be able to like hang out and watch movie and stuff. So there's not a lot of people there at that time. I mean, a lot of people there at that time. I mean, a ton of people showed up. Don't get me wrong. I just want to point out, arriving at 7.08 to something at 7 p.m. in Los Angeles is the same as arriving two hours early anywhere else in the country.
Absolutely. I know. Well, anyway, it was so cute. It was at this fancy, fancy estate with the view of the whole city, like that kind of thing. And there was cornhole, so me and Isabel played cornhole while we waited for people to get there. And then there was like a French fry like stand and with all the different dipping sauces.
Jenna, you know how much I love dipping sauces. This was heaven for me. I assume they're his dipping sauces. So we're hanging out. Of course. Yes, well of course. Okay, how many missteps can you make in one conversation? And he was so kind, bless his heart.
So he sees us from across this area, people are around him, and he makes a face like, hey, like that super like, hey, I've seen a friend. I was like, oh, yay. And Isabel's like, Mom, can I please just get one picture with him? I was like, yes, honey, we will make it happen. So we go up and we're chatting with him and he's so nice. Thankfully it was loud, so I don't think he heard me, but I said, congratulations on Smashed Kitchen.
This is so great. It's Smash Kitchen. Wait, Angela, didn't you do this with the TV show as well with the same name? I did it, the president of NBC, I said congratulations on Smash. Yeah, the TV show. That's now a Broadway musical.
Yeah, so clearly if I can't, it's not in my brain, it's gonna be smashed. I don't think he heard me, so that was good. But Isabel's face, you guys, bless her heart. She literally made this face like, oh my God, mom, seriously. He was like, well, thanks you guys so much for coming out. I said, yeah, we didn't have anything going on.
Straight to, great. Yeah. We're gonna miss. And Isabel just looked at me like, what? But anyway, he was lovely and we got a picture and I texted him later and I was like, thanks so much for inviting us out. And he was like, oh, you two cuties, thanks for coming.
So, Isabel was like, mom, should we stay a little bit later? People are starting to arrive. I'm like, no, no, no, honey. I was like, you don't understand what this valet line is gonna be like to leave this party. It's gonna be horrible. People are gonna be standing out here for an hour to get their car.
No, no, no. We were the first here. We're gonna be one of the first to leave this party. It's going to be horrible. People are going to be standing out here for an hour to get their car. No, no, no. We were the first here. We're going to be one of the first to leave and we will not be waiting for our car. And then guess who you missed. Well, so we left at 8 45 and we had a lovely time. Leo DiCaprio came. Leo. And you missed him?
Leo DiCaprio. Oh, the things you could have, the way you could have put your foot in your mouth to Leonardo DiCaprio. I know, I know. The things I could have, how much could I have gotten wrong? What do you think like you would have said to Leo wrong? Like anything revenant related, the bear? I know this would have been Titanic at best. Yeah, you were great in Titanic-dededed. Yeah, Titanic-ed. Is there anyone else you did or did not say hello to at this fancy party?
Oh, I did chat for a while with Lamorne Morris. I love him. Oh, he's great. And while we were chatting, this gal ran up, and by this point, it is like a packed party. And this gal sees us chatting and runs up to us with a little fuzzy microphone. You know how the influencers hold
the little tiny microphone? And they talk into it? I've never seen that in real life though. I had never seen it in real life either. And she was very nice, but she wanted to interview us about Smash Kitchen. And she asked us if a hot dog is a sandwich, if we think a hot dog is a sandwich.
I've heard this conversation. This is a hot topic. It is. And I was asked this one time for a newspaper article and people came for me so hard. So I basically was like, LeMorgne don't answer. They're gonna come for you.
What did you say? What did you answer last time? I said a hot dog is not a sandwich. And by the way, that's what Lamorne said too. And there are people who are like, hey, it is meat and two pieces of bread. It's a sandwich. So is a hamburger a sandwich?
That's what Lamorne said. No. And I was like, are like- Lamorne getting too loose with the word sandwich here. You know, is it meat between two pieces? Well, no, because peanut butter and jelly doesn't have meat, but that's a sandwich. Grilled cheese is a sandwich.
I don't think meat is a prerequisite for if something's a sandwich. Meat is not a prerequisite. It's a thing with two pieces of bread. But meatball sub is a sandwich. So what's the difference between a meatball sub and a hot dog? Really? Similar type of bread. Intense.
So I guess you're saying that a hot dog is a sandwich. I think I would say that a hot dog is a sandwich. I don't want to get into some weird Star Wars territory. I look forward to this being shared on a lot of site clickbait. Yeah, this is gonna be the clickbait for this episode. Yeah, I will say hot dog is not a sandwich because I've never been to a sandwich store
that sells hot dogs. That's a good, like Subway doesn't sell hot dogs. This is a good, they sell sandwiches. That's a very good observation. And I feel like if I asked for a hot dog at a nice sandwich place, they would say no. They would say, we don't have hot dogs here. Get out of here, sir.
They would judge you? Yeah, yeah. Get out of here with your stupid hot dog. Sir, this is a Wendy's, yeah. Yeah, so anyway, that was a big night for us at Spring Break. Huge. But Isabel had the best time and we got the cutest photo with Glenn
and he's just such a nice person. I'm so happy for him. Yeah, but I need my Smalltalk license. I need to go back to Smalltalk license school. I think you just need to avoid the word smash and you're gonna be okay. Anyone else want to share their spring breaks? Please, please don't let me be the only one.
I do want to say when I was driving into the studio today, Billie Jean King was getting her star on the walk of fame. Oh my gosh. Yeah, and I got stopped at the stoplight. I saw a woman giving a speech like right there. So I rolled down my window to be like, who is it? It was Jamie Lee Curtis. Yeah, and I got stopped at the stoplight. I saw a woman giving a speech, like right there. So I rolled down my window to be like, who is it? It was Jamie Lee Curtis.
And she was giving Billy a speech that made me be like, I wish she was my friend because she was like, Billy is power, power on the court, power and activism, power and being a friend. And I just felt like I was like at church sitting at this stoplight and it was amazing. It was really cool. What a cool and very,
this feels like a true Hollywood moment. Absolutely. Like, wow. You roll down your window and it's like Jamie Lee Curtis. Yeah. Wow. Jenna, I have a question for you. I just finished reading the book I was reading
and automatically, I just have a pile of books on my desk that are like up next to my queue. Why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Are you reading it right now? Because I'm so sorry because I gave up on it. I bailed on it. Didn't you bail on that, Jenna? Sam, it's because we were going to read Huckleberry Finn and then read this book, James,
which is a contemporary novel by Percival Everett. This was the book I wanted for Christmas was James. So it's this like retelling of the book, The Adventures of Huckleberry Finn. But that book is told from the perspective of Jim, who is the enslaved black man who accompanies Huck Finn on these quote unquote adventures. And so in the book, James, you're getting to hear everything
that Jim is thinking and feeling and who he is and his take on their adventure. And it's absolutely amazing. Great. Okay. and feeling and who he is and his take on their adventure. And it's absolutely amazing. Great. Okay. Cool. And so I had a lot of friends tell me that I would appreciate it more
or that it would be a richer experience for me if I reread Huckleberry Finn first. How far did you make it? I mean, where are you at Huckleberry Finn? I made it to their living on the island. Yeah. And Huckleberry Finn has faked his own death and now he's living on the island with James, with Jim.
Okay. So I gave up on Huckleberry Finn. I was like, sorry, Mark Twain. Yeah. This is not what I wanna read on my vacation. And I just started reading James and it's so good. And I am glad that I read a few chapters of Huckleberry Finn just to kind of like remind me John Wickett,
just to John Wickett. Sure, just to Lord of the Rings it. Have I John Wicked Sam into Huckleberry Finn? Sam was like, why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Why have I read three Huckleberry Finn novels back to back, why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Why have I read three Huckleberry Finn novels back to back? Why am I reading Mark Twain? I wish I had checked in and I had just finished the book and you're like, oh, I didn't read that at all.
No, no, no. I read a few chapters. Just skip to the thing that you really wanna read. Well, James is great. I really highly recommend it. Well, Jenna, you had a very relaxing spring break. Yeah. What was your takeaway from it?
Do you have a nugget of like something that you reconnected with in yourself? Well, I went to Hawaii for five days with my family, but I took off work the weekend before and the weekend after. So I had like this real separation from my work life for like that whole like nine days where like I truly put an away message on my emails
and I didn't open them on my trip. I did not do emails on my trip. Wow. I really put it away. And we also had this thing where we wanted to leave our phones in the room all day, me and Lee, because we just wanted to be like super present. Cause you know, Lee just wrapped his movie, but he didn't have to start editing until
this week. So we could both really put our work away and just be together as a family. And I said, well, the problem is if I have my phone and I'm taking pictures, then I see that I have a text or I see that I have a text or I see that I have a alert. So I like don't even want my phone on me, but I want pictures from this trip. So we went to Walmart
and we got a little like waterproof digital camera. Cool. And that is what we took all of our pictures on, minus a few pictures on our phone when we got dressed up and we were like, will someone please take a picture of us in front of the sunset. But almost all our pictures are on this thing.
And we also couldn't really see them. My eyesight wasn't great. If we were swimming or snorkeling, I had no idea if it was even on. I'd have to be like, is it on? Mom can't see without her glasses. Sure. We have the most craptastic photos from this trip.
Yeah. They are. Are they blurry? There are photos with like half a finger in front of the lens. We got a couple of those. Perfect, I love it. Eyes are half open, half closed.
Like sometimes people are in the frame, but they are so pure. They're like so, like they're better than any pictures we've ever taken on a vacation. I'm now in love with this idea of going on vacation with the craptastic camera. Yeah. And we are in love with these pictures.
They're so fun. But it was just, it was a great vacation. It was like, I really unplugged and I think that it helped change my relationship to my phone. Like I check my phone so much when I don't need to. Yeah, yeah. I always like have to have it near me.
I have like, you know, and so I want to keep that going. But then at the same time, I get home and I'm like, well, what if the school nurse calls or what if Lee stops at the grocery store and wants to know if we need a thing? And I'm like, sorry, babe, I just didn't want to look at my phone for three hours. You know, it's like I'm wrestling with like how to bring that home and I don't know how. Lady, lady. What is it? I have an idea for you. You are someone who has a landline.
Oh my God, you're right. The nurse, I need to start giving out my landline. The nurse, the landline, yes. But only give it to people who you would want to call through, right? Like to penetrate your world. So it's the school, it's Lee. Sure.
I mean me. You can have my line, line, line. But don't abuse it, Angela, or Jenna's gonna change your number. I won't abuse it, but I might start prank calling it. Well, I absolutely love that, Jenna. And I can't wait to see your digital photos. I'll be so excited to see them. You know what?
I should post some. I'll post, well, ask my family first. Because there are. Yeah, see which ones. I'll show you for sure in studio. I'll post some from the fancy party I went to in case I never get invited back to one. But we did have a huge life milestone happen
in our family today. Huge. Today was the first morning since our kids started school that we did not do carpool drop off because Jack has his driver's license and he's allowed to drive his siblings to school. And there's a parking lot for students that have a driver's license.
So today was the first morning ever that neither myself or Josh did carpool drop off. Wow. That is such a milestone. I remember talking to this dad and he said that in his opinion, your whole life changes twice when you're raising kids and they're both car related. He said, he was like, the first one is when you can say everyone get in the car and they can just get in it.
You don't have to strap them in. And like put on their seatbelt. And the second is when they can drive themselves. Like they're still living in your home, but they can drive themselves. Like they're still living in your home, but they can drive themselves. He's like, there are two car related milestones that like change everything about the dynamic of how you operate.
And I was, it's like, I didn't know what to do with myself as they walked out the door. I found myself just like yelling random things at them, like, I have extra fruit sticks. And they're like, exactly. Yes. Okay, okay, bye, bye, okay. Like, I know.
Yeah, that's a big deal. And then I had all this extra time this morning. I did stretches before my day. Look at you, lady. Maybe, maybe this is the year. You taking the time for you. Maybe this is the year. You're using that extra time for yourself. Maybe this is the year. You're using that extra time for yourself. That's right.
Maybe this is the year I touch my toes. Who knows? Jenna, I'm going to Coachella this weekend. I think I'm gonna take my phone off, or like leave it in my tent, and just take that film camera you guys got me for Christmas. Oh, yes. Yeah, those photos will trail.
So cool. Have fun. Are you gonna see Green Day at Coachella? I am gonna see Green Day at Coachella, yeah. Yay. Nice, very good. Well, this was a fun Friday chit chat. And before we go, I just want us all to say thank you to everyone out there that was part of us
getting nominated for a Webby Award. Yeah, thank you. Yes, we're nominated for comedy podcasts. We're in second place right now. That's right, you can vote until April 17th. We're nominated for comedy podcasts. We're in second place right now. That's right. You can vote until April 17th. We're going to put a swipe up in our stories. So we're officially nominated for best comedy podcast where you can go and vote for us.
Please do. And then we are a honoree for best comedy co-host. And I thank you for the honor. I am honored. It's just a declaration. Yeah, it's a declaration. So there you go. I'll take it. I'll take it. But we love doing this podcast. It means the world to us. So after all these years for people to put us in these categories of best comedy podcast, best co-hosts, I mean what
an amazing thing. So thank you. Yeah, thank you. I'll take it. I like it. Feels good. Feels good. It's a great way to get back on your phone. Yeah.
Yeah, that's a nice message to come home to for sure. All right, you guys. Well, we hope you have a great Friday and we're sending you hugs from over here at Office Ladies 6.0. Yeah. See you later. Bye.
See you later. Bye. Bye. See you later. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.